I was addicted to Xanax oh yeah I
brought a lot of Xanax for four years or
something like that when I was just
working a lot uh internationally I was
traveling and I was like oh look if I
take this
I'm gonna go to sleep I'm gonna go to
sleep for eight hours and I got into
this habit and then suddenly before I
knew it was like three four years I just
couldn't even think of sleeping without
uh Xanax and um
so I then decided I should stop and I so
I just stopped and I did two weeks where
every night I was like it's like I'd
been in a shower and then I got into bed
you know like it's or as wet as I could
be in a lying bed and I just sweats for
two weeks and people told me afterwards
it's super dangerous yeah it was an
alcohol I didn't the most dangerous stop
dead yeah oh stop you know you get dizzy
when you quit Xanax or is it just what
was the withdrawals lying awake at night
like oh but I just I knew that my I
really kind of crossed the line of my
fun uh times out you know weed and sort
of fun drugs but you know smack where I
grew up so this you know what I mean
there's like there's party side and
there's no to you you know what I mean
yeah it's like there's a whole different
yeah
because you know I was always so
ambitious it was like I couldn't
everyone all of my friends who did
heroin just that's what they did yeah
and I was I wanted to be in a fans that
wanted to be stoned and in a band you
know or do the band thing and then be
wasted at the end of it so I was always
had this focus and uh but it was pretty
scary that um that I just was like wow
what have you done to your body now for
two weeks straight up 14 days no not
much sleep and just pure sweating and
you know that was down to 161 which is
small for me you know because I'm like
heavier than that 85 or 190. so that was
pretty hardcore uh and of course they
any doctor give them to you so there was
no need to smuggle those the things that
were worse for me my whole life I was
just getting them from regular doctors
what years were how old were you in that
time that was about three weeks ago
[Laughter]
you know I had the most amazing moment
um on and I I it's a willful name drop
because it's fun for the program but I
had an incredible moment uh Mastodon is
one of my favorite bands okay I love
that band and we were playing
um rock M ring last year and there's
there's fever 333 Deftones uh Bush
Mastodon we're all on the same stage
um actually at the same time because I
was the day after uh Mastodon but I went
to watch them because I was a huge fan
of it and Brent so whatever and I didn't
know they're so heavy that I didn't know
if they'd like I don't know you know
somebody see Heavy bands you're like are
they going to be friendly are they going
to be like what's it going to be like
super friendly we had a friends we had a
mutual friend we'd done
um uh Ras Linux done a record with him
so I was always like oh the folklore of
Mastodon and they were super friendly
and I went over to them and um we took
pizza with them and I just met Brent
really quickly and I was like
he's asked me how I was doing I'd been
having trouble with my voice and I
wasn't feeling good and I was like when
I'm in Europe it I was gonna take
Xanax and I'm just gonna go back
to mosaics and my little pill bottle
with me and I was like I was gonna this
is I'll stop in a month when I finish
the tour I just got to get this tour my
voice I was telling myself the reasons
why I should take this Annex because you
know because the first couple of days
you're super jet lagged and you know
you're playing shows and you feel
and I said to him
I'm doing all right and I rattled this
thing in my pocket and I said but I
think that
I I shouldn't probably do it right I
think I'm going to go back on this train
and he goes he goes don't yeah he go
well how did you get from meeting
someone how did you get from not taking
Xanax to having them in your pocket oh
because because because I I I'd flown
over with him so the one time I will
take them is on a transatlantic flight
I'll pop one just to sleep at night and
then I was like that's it then you get
there and then I thought so I had him on
me and I've had a few rough days and I
was like should I or shouldn't I and I
again this whole thing about this is
um uh synchronicity and com you know
meeting people I met him and I said to
him
yeah I've seen my voice I don't feel
good in my voice and I don't feel very
healthy and I'm being an idiot but I
really might think I might just spend a
month you know doing shows and eating
Xanax so I can get through this and he
then went on to tell me about that his
journey with it how he's addicted to it
for way longer of course you know way
heavier than me way longer than me on
Xanax and he was telling me about how
actually
um it makes you like everything your
everything goes to everything slows down
to the point of close to death
everything slows down all the organs
everything completely that's what it is
everything slows down the NX does that
yeah he's the benzos that's what they do
so I was like I just hugged him you know
what I mean we just I hugged him and I
was like you just saved me because your
wisdom and insight uh experience just
made me
not do that so I kept the pills
obviously
and by using the promo code Stevo you
get 20 off your order plus free shipping
man I love manscaped you love manscaped
jump on this deal support the podcast
and have a killer summer looking really
good one more time
manscaped.com promo code Stevo